Yuuki Suoba
Look at the deer This
is the true tissue armed dan
Grand Park and granulated sugar in a bowl.
It
seems that you are using attachments with a complicated shape
.
Perfectly controlling and cooking
Salt carving knives can be applied to cake making
Cooking and other
things will degenerate from the old days Show me more Sgt
.
Even if you try to detonate the detonator,
see if
something like a thin pie crust enters the
oven.Is it a special forwarding oven for baking a participatory machine
?If you don't want to break the membrane, cover your ears
] The
sweet scent of waiting to burn envelops and cuts the future.
While I was there, the enemy was already a
man A
beauty that can't be imagined from a victory blow
What a classy cake It's hard to stop in my legs
Yeah Joy
Oh